in the scanner from micro range scanning
of rock art which has deliberately been
built for that purpose
what you see here on the floor is a
small portion of a 3d print of ancient
rock art packed into large rock pans in
valcamonica in Italy this has been
reconstructed in 3d printed and is now
just used as a demonstrator object what
we would do out in the wild is put the
scanner on top of the art to be scanned
first button what you see is a flash and
what you may be here I can do it another
time later when the green light is
owning it you can now hear two different
pictures being taken in succession first
one with flash second one without flash
and also you see it's two SLR cameras
here what we are taking is a pair of
images with flash and another pair
without flash looking at the specifics
of the flash
this is custom design 220 high-intensity
white LEDs cast a very humid chinos
field of illumination down on the ground
pictured by this stereo setup of the two
cameras we take a stereo pair with
illumination another one without
illumination and by subtracting these
frames from each other we can virtually
shroud the influence of daylight so we
can even eliminate cast shadows which
would be cast by direct sunlight and
that ends up with radiometrically
corrected images which just show the
radiometric surface properties under
artificial illumination radiometric
means color but in addition what we also
model is by reconstructing the 3d
surface we have direction of
illumination calibrated for each of
these 220 LEDs we have a few angle of
the camera and we have surface normal of
the particular surface element so we can
really model the interplay between
incident light surface normal of a small
surface patch and viewing direction in
the end we reconstruct a dense
3d point cloud where each point carries
radiometric information color
information about each element in this
point cloud on the rock surface a points
a bit like pixels in this coordinates
actually it's not not the same as pixels
in an image because even if it is very
very dense there is a lot of space
around the individual point so it is 3d
coordinates a file full of 3d
coordinates you could say and the each
of these points carrying additional
information in this case RGB if you try
to visualize that you would see a lot of
dots and either
if you splatter them if you makes a
spherical approximation of this
infinitesimal small point yeah you would
end up in viewing it you would perceive
it as a surface but actually it is
points a bit like a computer vision of
atoms yeah it could be so here there is
customer electronic including a
Raspberry Pi on the PI it runs Linux and
it just controls the cameras actually it
then fetches the capex and via vilas
transfer it transfers it to a tablet PC
which normally is taken by the
archaeologists with him laying on the
rock just beside the scanner and on this
tablet PC online we get rough 3d
reconstruction from JPEGs at the same
time we store the raw images in the
cameras on the storage cards and going
home we take the raw images for doing
this fine radiometric evaluation using
structure from motion plus stereo we get
correctly scaled point clouds which
means it is a point cloud where
distances can be measured distances
between different points however this
point counted could be anywhere in the
world if we would like to relate what we
scan to what has been scanned before
side by side maybe we need common
coordinate system that's the other trick
with the scanner here
what you see there is a micro prism so
this prism is very precisely measured by
a total station
it's a various instrument it could be
fueled as a theodolite where you also
measure the distance from the
measurement device to this prism not
just angles originally when we developed
the thing we started and asked for
measurements every time the pattern is
the button is pressed right but in the
end it turns out if you for instance
need say hundred scanning positions to
scan a reasonable area of rock it would
be enough to do a few of these prism
measurements just at nicely balanced
locations to finally be able to
translate and rotate this 3d model in a
way that it perfectly fits with key
reference coordinates of whatever has
been scanned pictured reconstructed by
the archaeologists otherwise it is
altitude as well it is the 3d position
in geographical coordinates of this
particular prism this is the one 3d P
rocket scanner prototype most of the
time it's proofed over quite well then
something went wrong it mostly concerned
communication via the violets to the
tablet PC if it's too far away we have
then we added some aluminum shielding
here this also blocks the wireless
communication in some cases but there
are minor issues actually the other
thing is this device will measure only
perfect if it is well calibrated so it
had to be shipped back to our department
in Graz for fine recalibration we also
designed some targets so that it could
be calibrated in the wild in the
archaeological campaign but best
calibration was of course obtained at
home you know in our measurement lab
it's a nice thing it has worked very
well and robustly over one and a half
years almost but it's unique so that's a
drawback of course
we have already submitted a proposal to
the EU for follow-up project there this
should be turned into a product zone
then this product would be available as
a commercial product for archaeologists
all over the world and probably it can
be used for many other questions of 3d
reconstruction of surface shape
including surface radiometry
it is color may be even extended to
invisible wavelengths I travel at
infrared
the final one it should become a product
it should prevail under 5000 euros this
one was a little more expensive because
it had to be assembled from many
components and there was also some trial
and error